good morning look better way to start
the day then a nice drone sunrise shot
really think of the drone this is it
have you even seen it Bri watched me on
the do the launch break make me play it
will always be that there's no doubt in
my mind you will always be the head out
to sea and lead of SPI cuz you will
always be there cuz you will always be
the one to always be the one hello
everyone welcome to another day here in
Hawaii right now we're gonna be going to
Black Rock see if we can see some
turtles we may also go shopping cuz
there's a mall here I'm probably gonna
bring out the drone got it in my
backpack like always I don't leave home
without it anymore unless I forget or
it's not charged what keep this way yes
it's constructed them
yep you're right
freeze right I hear there's a little
lemon here that truth drill huh it's
been a year so I don't know
but it was here a year ago I need a very
short oh yeah I'm definitely droning a
black rock you tossed me like a stone
[Music]
you swept me off my feet back in my
bones I still count the days
you swept me off my feet got the shot
keep going though we got to get some
short new tank tops
o new SH I don't have janitor in here
great news got myself a pair of shorts
can you believe one would travel to
Hawaii and not even bring a single pair
of shorts granted I don't really wear
shorts but of them by the pool I think I
might want to you know I don't want to
Wow okay you told me it was fine I could
feel the pain
this is no wait this looks like like a
largely circling this place wait oh yeah
we waited for an hour an hour we only
have five tables my favorite place
this is the second time we've had
breakfast today but Breanna that we can
come here you cannot not get breakfast
so here we are
yep ready breeze beeping in the car
beatbeat very brief while it's really
windy now I know you just saw is eating
breakfast in this vlog which was
actually lunch but we are heading to a
luau now I haven't been to one in a
really really long time I don't really
remember what they do I know that
there's like a pig and they cook the pig
and there's dancing and fire knives and
a lot of crazy things dancing and Fire
or not yep you ready for this luau Bri
yep I'm gonna get it started soon
yeah cuz I got a drone before the pig
roast it's gonna happen it's happening
it's happenin a grouse is happening in
15 minutes oh no oh goodness we got a
roast
everyone's piling out of this minivan
heading to the luau baby I gotta get
this sunset shot the Sun is going down
I've only got about a half an hour good
girl yeah see you suckers later thank
you the first look is gonna help
yourself to some drinks thank you a
eunuch
ha really good Chris history thanks I
get
I'm standing in my
[Music]
I was trying to feel it
some summaries travel with Stu
[Music]
when I was trying to feel
yeah I was trying to feel it
it's so windy I just flew the drone and
I definitely gotten up a wind advisory
warnings but I still pull it up and down
just a little bit but then I brought it
right back because the last thing I want
to do is lose this thing because I don't
have a replacement I did bring the
Phantom 4 but the Mavic is so much fun
and is so fast and so easy to use that I
just love it so much we're getting a
little time-lapse right now with the
sunset it's really pretty although we're
a little nervous about these clouds in
the background
it looks like it's gonna straw
[Music]
I still have
so they're going to dig and I'm going to
stay here watch the items so here's a
clip of a jig from Jenna thank you so
cool like the main staple of my diet
just like rice potatoes are in the main
line boy is here in Hawaii we're getting
food there's a buffet there's a pig the
pig kind of made me uncomfortable I
don't like it coming us not meeting pig
again we just had dinner
it was lovely now I've heard a rumor
that they're gonna have audience members
dance on stage
wait members as in plural perhaps that's
what I heard and let me tell you what if
I don't get pointing to
I'm gonna be you want to go to as
handsome boy I'm going up I'm going up
I met a bullet dream I met Audrey
I'm embarrassed for my seat I'm proud of
my dance moves and I did the best that I
could do so there's that it was nothing
else no now since I've been traveling
I'm thinking about travel apps that I
use when I trap there's tons and tons
and tons of travel apps I don't really
use that many specific travel apps but
when I am traveling I made myself a
little travel folder so I thought I
would show you guys what I use to sort
of keep my life organized keep myself in
check and basically things that